what's going on guys so American
Independence Day is tomorrow and that
got me thinking about America's greatest
birthday present ever the movie
Independence Day
now if the Internet's correct two years
from now we're gonna see a sequel to
Independence Day ID forever
what do we want to see in a sequel to
Independence Day that brings us to our
new segment dream sequels where we will
conjure great ideas that Hollywood will
never use and we have an awesome panel
to talk about our dream Independence Day
sequels first he's been with us a number
of times before welcome back from
belated media Michael barity glad to be
here how and uh this man is one of the
gentlemen behind one of the best film
sites out there slash film welcome
Jermaine Lussier thank you very much out
so from what we hear we're expecting the
sequel two years from now so let's take
everything we know and flush it down the
toilet second we might be happening
right now we don't know what do we want
to see what what's gonna blow our minds
for starters I'd like to just address
what the poster should be yes and the
tagline mm-hmm it should be we thought
we were free we were wrong oops
Jermaine what what well I was thinking
about the dream sequel I kept thinking
they can't do my real dream sequel which
is when you first saw the first movie
how do we rebuild since so much time has
passed we can't make that movie so I
came up with two crazy scenarios I'd
like to say okay
the first one is the less plausible one
we still have the alien spaceship let's
go back and see what we can find out and
it becomes aliens meets Independence Day
I want to see us on their planet or on
their ship just mowing down guys we sent
off colonial Marines to take out the
Alien Swarm wherever it is as that
happens wormhole opens up and there's an
another attack on earth so you're
remaking the first movie but also having
a seven-story of right I like that see
and that's good because it helps me take
my screenplay from like six pages to a
lot more than that so I now we've got 12
no no go the other thought I had in
conjunction with an alien sort of thing
the other idea I had was aliens show up
and made more or less create a giant
solar flare that
oops out all of the electricity on earth
so we now need to be using analog
technology just to make it a thing where
we have like Minutemen sort of action of
like militias and things like that so
it's really down and dirty and you've
got the world sort of in this weird
panic where we're at our weakest so I
really like this idea of the two
storylines with the colonial Marines on
one battlefront but then the aliens are
attacking us on earth again so who do we
want to pepper into that movie who's
back from the first movie no Harry
Connick jr. sorry sorry buddy do we want
Will Smith back I would love him without
question
yeah but he's I mean in that character
was the main character so like 20 years
later for him not to be there seems kind
of weird
even if his son the rumor is that like
Michael B Jordan might be playing was
that in the room yeah and yeah Jordan
has a fantastic definitely sigh
definitely took meetings about it that's
that happened but it was actually to do
it if that's actually the movie but
anyway they could get Smith's to do a
five-minute cameo you think maybe he's
been off on the alien planet this whole
time without anybody knowing because
he's such a great pilot he comes back
with like all this technology big mech
suit avatar style yeah right as the
credits roll he's like we got a problem
gap comes back to earth yeah I know yeah
and I think you mean the fact that
Pullman and Goldblum are back perfect I
mean with no Will Smith you need to
bring back as many people as you can
absolutely they're both great but you
need a big action star at the front yeah
you need some muscle I think the obvious
choice is Dwayne the rock Johnson yeah
he's well versed in action and comedy so
he can play more or less the Will Smith
role you know might be kind of fun if
like the rock just played himself
because we're living in this post alien
invasion world and he's like man we're
not making movies anymore I guess I'm
gonna have to kick ass for real all
right
that is interesting it's like do movies
count anymore after the world's been
decimated Independence Day right so
unless there have been some
constitutional changes after the alien
attack Bill Pullman can't be president
anymore true um so who's president now
as much I just want to recast aliens as
this movie Bill Paxton Oh that'll be
really confusing with the bleep uh he
gave a really good speech in Pacific Rim
but no
a ton of people saw Pacific Rim so let's
say Idris Elba oh I love I bring him in
bringing the whole cast of wired every
different all Michael B Jordan
we got Aegis Elba love take Method Man
yes yes cheese needs to be in there who
would we want to avoid I don't want the
Megan Fox ofin of this movie we don't
need any you know overly hot or sexual
blonde character so just on that note
having a kick-ass woman in there is one
of the colonial Marines have it a little
Michelle Rodriguez I want brie Larson is
one of the real artist is that nobody
casts and by then hopefully maybe she's
stellar yeah under everything she's been
and she tried to be Sarah Connor in the
Terminator didn't get it with Emilia
Clarke also great but let's get brie her
action movie come on
so we're talking about our dream sequel
the current title they have on the books
is ID forever man it's okay but is there
a new title that we like better is there
a new holiday Memorial Day could work
yeah I don't think we have a Memorial
Day movie yet or Veterans Day
Independence Day - Veterans Day
Independence Day three Memorial Day guys
I think we've really painted a great
picture here - sweet we have the actors
we have the title Independence Day -
Veterans Day fellas wouldn't it be great
if we could see the trailer for that
movie I can help with that what the
voice of honest trailers John Bailey
here in studio hi I have hi fights on
Bailey
so you'd be willing to help us you bet
your ass I will on July 2nd they arrived
on July 3rd they attacked on July 4th we
fought back now 20 years later they're
back but this time we are bringing the
fight to them and in space everyone can
hear freedom ring
[Music]
when the lights go out on planet earth
the fireworks begin Jeff Goldblum Bill
Pullman Bill Paxton Michael B Jordan
iris Elba brie Larson the cast of The
Wire featuring Will Smith and Dwayne the
rock Johnson as itself
Independence Day - Veterans Day we
thought we were free we were wrong oops
man the real movie will never live up to
that did you like our trailer do you
want to go tweet it to roland emmerich
or do you think it could be something
better tell us in the comments below
the best answer we're gonna send you
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
all my guests today
Michael Baron T of belated media and
Jermaine Lussier of slash film check out
that awesome film site and John Bailey
thanks for coming to the studio brother
my pleasure
oh man that voice since you're here you
are master of voices and impressions
would you mind doing my signature outro
to the that camera right there course
I'm out run it if you have on Twitter
bye-bye
I like I mean if you see him is just
like a little troll like then it's great
because then it's like oh he could
totally get them out of this like
situation it's not what a safe okay